By the time you watch this video 765 people
will be born and 321 people will die.
You've been watching this video for 21 seconds
and in that time Americans have eaten 7,350
slices of pizza.
By now 28,416 barrels of oil have been used.
By now 19,000 tonnes of water have flown over
Niagara Falls.
By now 690 million tonnes of water has evaporated
from the surface of the Earth.
By now there have been 5 earthquakes across
the world.
By now 6 million chemical reactions have taken
place inside your body.
By now Apple has made another $339,930 dollars
and Samsung has made $475,833 dollars.
By now 2,550 trees have been cut down in the
rainforest.
By now 4 violent crimes have happened in the
United States.
By now the Universe has expanded by 4,200
miles.
By now humans have killed 307 sharks.
By now 480,000 stars have been born in the
observable universe and 3,000 stars have exploded.
By now 101 aeroplanes have taken off around
the World.
By now 212 people have gotten married.
By now lightning has struck earth 9,000 times.
By now 5.6 million likes have been made on
Facebook and 800,000 photos have been uploaded
to Facebook.
By now 1.1 million tweets have been posted
on Twitter.
By now 468,000 hours of video has been watched
on YouTube.
By now $334,000 worth of goods has been sold
on Amazon.
And by now 544 million emails have been sent,
70% of which are spam.